yeah hello and welcome to this video of
a spontaneous decision to join this it's
an hourly super blitz arena and I'm late
I didn't want to me now I know those are
sometimes interesting and me catching up
but I wanted to UM rather play the full
tournaments once but it just what what
happened I had to get some food from the
supermarket and I forgot to berserk
that's better
I mean not bad as in bad but I wanted to
berserk
I came get z5x to think about preserving
after that okay so he puts the knight on
to h5 that's not really having that many
squares
maybe I'm just threatening g-form now it
just looks look a bit weird he does not
want to play f5 strategically in this
position that looks bad making his
bishop at night look silly and I have
rook g1 an immediate problem also just
to preserve this game anyway let's see
I'm still winning stuff
my skill he is getting some porn maybe
like kim taek's is reunited walking f1
that is definitely - it's a little bit
strange but materially speaking I'm fine
yeah I have to have a flying doctor's
again I have to give them that
additional pole but the remaining pieces
are very good particular form so anyway
- this one 94 got a coffee probably
helpful just a little bit annoyed that I
didn't deserve
trading one book is certainly an idea I
went to heaven I want to have this like
turkey leg
I want them to have the bad dark-squared
bishop at the end but now that is not
valid anymore after that go to grep but
um it's still okay yeah I would give you
I need to get rid of his Bishop Pam this
is clear 92 was my intention
and head on the clock quite a bit that's
good he wants to go we should go 644 is
a good square for the King wait is
actually just rendering this right so
let me take it comic revision taken from
one age six but this is not bad either
almost supreme move which you never know
King is perfectly safe on evil where is
the checkmate there should be a job made
Luke hae dismayed yeah yeah there will
sell us too slow actually I should have
deserved but I just forgot about it
[Music]
no pairing
I need games okay oops
what's so here the Klein Meister small
master tactical shorter than 21 years in
with a bishop and that's good oops oops
[Music]
g5g for threatens I'd like to move on to
winter the pawn which is doing this it's
also quite helpful I can win the pawn
probably I should do it also this energy
form maybe taking money to first was
more precise now that I think of it you
might take on f5 now you know not sure
how good is this but it is somewhat
irritating and I'm actually a Ruka it
doesn't real get all Wow hey funny miss
Cowell yeah I'm just a huge material up
still it's a little bit need some
precision some colander precision is
strong air just shouldn't blunder the
house he's got some weak back rank which
no direct way to benefit from it
yeah Lucas hanging and let's me take it
Weiner for he gets checkmated so he now
has to play very small window a crank
covering a5 and whatever and we find
Anthony hook see what made us the main
thing that you cannot really defend I
think come on faster 21 points at stuff
come on the line - actually from Russia
and simply have left as them okay this
does it help I could and there's no way
to auto preserve right
[Music]
[Music]
so I'm gaining some space here in this
now I'm gaining the pawn that's not bad
take the big center pawn yeah okay
add the pretty good opening results with
winning the d5 for absolutely nothing
and I'm quickly canceling long we should
give three maybe coming yeah yeah my
develop development is pretty good
Bishop a6 even good work
[Music]
yeah I'm threatening to take on d7
simply and not quite sure how he defends
against that probably heads we should be
five as well now that I think of it
Bishop on g5 or is there some trick that
I'm not seeing
very wealthy keep the bishop cupboard
and I take the night yeah you should see
six would be good yeah to get in but
don't get this end so easily
so probably retreat this to be three and
then see what we can do
whoa that looks a bit unsafe
let's get it out of those chicks for
four more I did see that it was hanging
but I think I was thinking the attack is
just too strong I get for coming and so
on when I should better win my mate
that's better with the time situation c6
maybe I still have this to build fill it
with okay so tactical wizard wasn't here
leading this thing now who is leading
this thing I should get out of the first
page to see where I'm actually trying to
catch okay I've got 10 points yeah my
tried and trusted line oops right III
what you're doing I'm just developing
should've taken only three actually
really it would have been would have
been Ted easier isn't actually that
clear
surprisingly I'm okay yeah but it isn't
like brilliant really hasn't well the
ship ego maybe yeah it could be a
problem
[Music]
shouldn't shouldn't get my queen bee
getting trapped but my bishop won't be
sick should be stronger here expire than
his construction let's take it and it's
now a move okay
there's an open anymore left all which I
actually missed
[Music]
maybe that was not so clever here just
because of the time CZs to eg6 probably
I can just get a sample where's the
Queen actually help that people would
resign at a decent moment but anyway
cannot influence that ten points lady
tactical shall take them they miss
settle win every single game zyo bio was
winning every single game now okay 25
minutes mm on the first page that should
be possible you need to be - it's really
really aggressive okay now you just
develop playing likes left of flower
reversed
you can do all kinds of things but it's
not really very threatening Oh
surprising maybe you can take angle
reform but it would have been
interesting maybe yes probably just
equal maybe maybe my position is a bit
easier because my C file and that is not
a good move actually and it's to
simplifying I should have played Bishop
e7 shouldn't click push yourself
this is helping really is come on you're
not designing this God we don't get I
mean they also cannot score anymore in
those situations a5 maybe man just
quicker
yeah
screw you and I don't get it so pull it
off of the drawer
maybe wanted to resign I know that's the
clock run down no okay I'm sorry that
was Miss clicks is possible and just
makes no sense to me to store the games
okay
so five points behind behind you stuff
cool
[Music]
Madonna made whatever hey mate in the
maintenance or something let's go quick
development and maybe I can run up an
attack on the king's fight with f3 g4
and stuff yeah 95 maybe you can do that
okay
Knight c5 might be on the cards so
annoying this move probably I go 95
immediately here to avoid this thing
[Music]
full centralization takes with this
he's defending was quite good quite well
it was a pretty bad opening position I
think and from from days playing it
quite good quite well what am I doing
here oh really
Queen f6 oh my god
threatening I hate threatening f4 yeah
that's easy to see unfortunately it's
not a check which is at least it's not
an immediate Queen trade it's not good
maybe you can do something every should
see to end 22 it is completely killing
me I done playing crap really really
badly Queen d2 yeah you see everything
ah terrible here you cannot afford stuff
like that loose against the 1910
especially actually not from such a good
position in the opening I know it takes
time everything wins queen a4 or
whatever
it's another move I would have played
but maybe it's not so bad it's not so
easy technically 23 minutes or seconds
and you have to do it 30 a dirty time
winged him no I don't know other
possibility I wasn't bidding be going
boom silly play move it looks really bad
we played that really well you can train
any yeah
whenever's irking that's not my spot
yes
endgame variation it was played by
Lasker in the same game against kappa
blanka 19 Wow
I am Not sure actually not sure about
the year thinking it wasn't st.
Petersburg I think but I'm not
completely sure about the time I think
it was before the World Championship
Mexico
I think Laska was still the world
champion at all time I'm not completely
sure them yeah so here I've got the
Bishop pale and white has the better
structure and if this is a well-known
position type of course from the
exchange variation 94 would be would
have been quite a quite annoying
actually if not downright bad for me so
how do you do this it's not much fun to
play I mean black doesn't really have
any problem but you don't have o much to
look look forward to either I'm going to
see 5 B should be 17 - 17 c6 I probably
windows on time take me there or not on
position that easily
I don't like white can do much should I
focus in some way here not too good a
game playing g5 you have an h5 maybe but
again I don't have anything very well
played by white
but I think now I'm just winning a pawn
that's much it's still very very dry of
course but yeah very well defended by
Victorian s okay so I got I got to the
first place with 12 minutes left looking
okay now but but I was really lucky in
that game where I am one on time down
Kingdom but you at least can hope that
you get you can win a quick away if not
some some ultra long ending or so I'm
just developing he still have to win
back f4 which is not going to be super
easy
I'm abt with the porn actually the C
file half opened could be useful
hooks the aid and stuff night welcome to
e3 song try to regroup it bishops on
special one c6 is also an idea
okay let's take this first and now I'm
actually getting to you 3 C 3 is also
hanging not sure that this is so
important but wow it's still it's cool
there when in exchange it's a temp 1 on
the White Queen to get rid of that
Bishop with it
absolutely well it is ok at a 6 is week
C 3 is weak I should be able to win this
and I'm catching up on time
because would be one I cannot take due
to the back ring so I have to insert a
move like g6 this is the same thing the
background mate looks a frequent a group
takes to create mate so g6 was
unnecessary but I can take this now
[Music]
that's it for the white queen okay
all of a sudden six points okay eight
minutes left they would have preserved
the first one I think that forces would
just be an additional point yeah it's
not a big difference to cool here we go
let's number two hmm
could have done that a little bit more
conservatively there was no real need to
preserve this it's a very comfortable
position for me
it's quite nice queen f 4 and so on just
be sped on the kingside the main thing
here is the time situation
you cannot really take I think night
each for and yeah now now f5 may be
necessary weakening five because taking
it's already okay but it's still
fantastic blushing naturally for is
coming I can take one g5m it doesn't
quite work
[Music]
still defending this quite well 9f5 is a
threat probably will move the king and
then that's not easy to play for me this
one here I should play c3 actually yeah
you can almost certainly take a for next
Queen f7 is on the cards on in 95 so one
of seven is almost certainly drawn no
it's not actually is this group g7 now
after you have 11 seconds I should win
this of course it was a winning position
I think I will miss something 94 5 or so
we should have been a full wing down
okay that not losing was good it didn't
change the status quo here in the
standings not quite sure what was
possible there I must have been away
the scandinavian 196 it's one of those
openings value Bucky will never equal
eyes with black patio you can limit the
magnitude of your disadvantage pretty
pretty well it wasn't a bomb actually
what I did Jen that wasn't good man
it still kind of okay but 83 was some
not well timed I like c8 is very what
you're thinking about but yeah things
was better
no totally totally disregarded it's five
hangs yeah now black is fine of course
not here it's fine whether his Bishop is
the better piece now a well no not on
you but it's equal
oh why am I looking stuff like this that
I would like to system that I would like
to know or this and what the heck
no no this was planned of course and I
have 20 something seconds while you have
his own time great yes it could have
shaken already would have been much
better of course nonsense
I should actually resign this stuff I
know half we know spoiling this on the
very last game against the ceiling
Scandinavian with 90 of 6 and with the
openings are already fallen but it's
you really should just be bad end and
press hard with age three yeah I
probably get overtaken our stuff cool is
still playing or I don't know maybe
maybe actually stuff who is losing this
huh so I might win it after all I'm not
winning it I'm not winning it this is so
frigging your takeout can you lose the
final game I really don't understand
anyway I'm just so plain stupid I mean
that you almost Terrell Hall was
terrible and of course you have to win
the final round against someone with
1900 anyway okay hope you'll still
enjoyed the games and thanks for
watching bye bye